c'est probablement l'histoire qui a le
plus nourri l'hypothèse d'une existence
d'une vie extraterrestre on est au début
du mois de juillet 1947 et dans une
ferme très isolé à quelques dizaines de
kilomètres de la ville de roswell au
nouveau-mexique
il ya un fermier label william mc bradl
qui découvre un matin des débris un peu
bizarre dans son champ l'armée va
arriver va regarder les débris et
quelques heures plus tard va sortir un
communiqué sur ce communiqué l'armée
quasiment reconnais mais c'est assez
compliqué en fait à le lire qu'on a
retrouvé des débris d'une soucoupe le
terme soucoupe ne veut pas forcément
dire soucoupe volante égale
extraterrestre mais ça va nourrir
l'hypothèse que l'armée elle même
reconnaît l'existence d'extraterrestres
à roswell au nouveau-mexique
au début du mois de juillet 1947 alors
ça n'a pas duré très longtemps parce que
très vite
l'armée fait une espèce de démentir dix
ans mais non il s'agit de ballon météo
comme on en voit beaucoup au dessus de
cette zone là les débris ne sont pas des
débris extraterrestre pas du tout
circulez ya rien à voir
et on fait même des photos avec des
soldats montrant les débris ce qui est
intéressant de cette rumeur c'est que
elle va totalement disparaître pendant
des décennies honnêtement pendant
plusieurs décennies
on ne parle plus de roswell et des
extraterrestres à roswell
le démenti de l'armée a suffi à éteindre
la chose tout va rebondir à la fin des
années 1970
on est quand même trente ans plus tard
en 1978 il ya un death premiers
militaires qui étaient intervenus à
l'époque qui est un homme qui travaille
au renseignement
jesse marcel qui est interviewé par un
ufologue les ufologues c'est les
spécialistes des extraterrestres qui
croient en général ces belles stanton
friedman et il dit à ce temps donne
friedman
à l'époque l'armée a bidonné la chose
ils ont mis de débris à la place
d'autres débris ce ne sont pas les vrais
débris qu'on a mis moi je crois en
l'existence d'extraterrestres ce temps
tom friedman se dit jeu
la bonne histoire la belle histoire le
national enquire grand magazine
américain va en faire un article
et l'histoire va commencer à monter
comme ça il ya un livre en 1981 qui
vraiment marque la bascule ce livre il
écrit par deux auteurs
moore et berlitz qui écrivent un livre
l'incident roswell qui raconte toute
l'histoire en fait qui largement
collecte bien des ennemis bien des
décennies plus tard des témoignages sur
rejoignent 1947
on va raconter des tas d'histoires on va
même ajouté une information qu'on
n'avait pas du tout en 1947 qui est que
et il le raconte dans le livre des
étudiants en archéologie ont retrouvé
des traces d'extraterrestres au sol
plusieurs extras terrestres qui ont
ensuite été enlevée par l'armée parce
qu'il ne fallait pas laisser de traces
les extraterrestres était là parce qu'il
y aurait eu un crash entre deux ovnis
entre deux soucoupes volantes dans
l'espace dans le ciel au dessus de
roswell et ce livre là va vraiment être
le point de départ de ce qu'on appelle
l'histoire de la rumeur de roswell dans
les années 80 dans les milieux d'abord
des ufologues des spécialistes des ovnis
roswell devient un nom qui revient de
plus en plus alors qu'il avait
totalement disparu entre 1947 et 1980 le
mot apparaît de plus en plus roswell
devient à la mode et surtout dans les
années 90 et le troisième temps premier
temps quarante septième temps années 70
80 et troisième temps les années 90
alors là c'est l'explosion
l'explosion du phénomène roswell qui
regardent et x-files x files et lancé en
1994 et x-files va faire énormément
d'épisodes sur roswell d'ailleurs la fin
d'extase première partie avant d'être
relancé en 2012 c'est quoi c'est la
certitude pour les deux personnages les
deux enquêteurs d'x-files que les
extraterrestres existent parce qu'il ya
roswell roswell c'est la preuve qu'il y
à des extraterrestres en 1997 cnn faire
un sondage une enquête et montre que les
américains croient massivement aux
extraterrestres en raison de l'histoire
de rose
l'armée est sommé de répondre mais
qu'est ce qui s'est passé à roswell
il ya de plus en plus de demandes
sociales et de demandes politiques
le congrès et le gouvernement demande à
l'armée de présenter un démenti sérieux
sur ce qu'il s'est passé à roswell et ça
va être deux gros dossiers de gros
rapports de dizaines de centaines de
pages qui vont expliquer qu'en fait à
roswell ce qui s'est passé la version de
1947 donné par l'armée était fausse
c'était pas des ballons météo
l'armée dit on a menti ce qui est assez
rare mais il s'agissait pas
d'extraterrestres ce que dit l'armée
c'est qu'il s'agissait d'un progrès un
programme secret le projet mongole et ce
projet moule secret c'était en fait
d'envoyer dans l'espace des sondes pour
aller surveiller les efforts soviétique
pour se doter d'une arme nucléaire
et c'est cette sonde qui serait tombée
sur le sol et qu'on aurait remplacé
effectivement par des d'autres débris
qui ferait croire davantage à un ballon
météo
voilà la réponse de l'armée alors vous
imaginez bien que pour les gens qui
croient aux extraterrestres le fait que
l'armée ait menti une fois peut-être
c'est la porte ouverte à des mensonges
supplémentaires mais aujourd'hui on en
est là alors ce qu'il ya après nuri le
fantasme de roswell c'est en 1995 un
film un type un anglais aurait sans
doute il y sera un film et ce film est
prétendu mans l'autopsié d'un de ces
fameux extraterrestre tombé à roswell en
1947 où on voit avec des images un peu
sale un peu crade des gens qui font les
autopsies de ce qui apparaît être un
extraterrestre
on saura assez vite que est lui-même val
avouer que le film est totalement
on met il à relancer vraiment cette
cette hypothèse roswell qui aujourd'hui
avec tous les démentis de l'armée toutes
les preuves sont mais mêmes cette
hypothèse même elle est reconnue comme à
ces fausses par les grands du faux locke
d'aujourd'hui 1 qui disent roswell
c'est probablement pas la preuve qu'il
existe des extraterrestres mais pour
beaucoup de gens les extraterrestres
c'est la zone 51 mais c'est aussi
roswell aujourd'hui roswell aujourd'hui
c'est une ville où il ya une industrie
énorme autour de cette vie
extraterrestre il ya des musées il ya
évidemment des boutiques peut imaginer
aux états unis donc c'est clair que
roswell n'a peut-être jamais existé en
tout cas aujourd'hui roswell existe bel
et bien et roswell est bel et bien un
verre alors c'est pas le verre des
extraterrestres c'est plutôt le verre
des dollars parce qu'aujourd'hui c'est
une véritable industrie qui s'est
développée au nouveau mexique